il n'hésite pas à se jeter à l'eau pour
faire la promotion de la martinique
christophe et sa passion la chasse sous
marine font l'objet d'un film pour la
chaîne seasons 17 jours de prises de
vues sur terre et en mer où lui et
l'équipe de tournage ont côtoyé cet
autre monde
a la martinique est quand même un
endroit où il ya beaucoup d'endroits où
la vie sous marine est encore tout à
fait riche et préservé chez ici tout un
tas de poissons qu'on ne trouve vraiment
quand que dans les caraïbes
le capitaine par exemple après il ya
beaucoup de poissons récifaux du décor
et qui participe à la joie d'éclat le
requin dormeur ont fait partie voilà
d'ailleurs on a eu l'occasion d'en voir
lors du tournage au vauclin alors que
c'est assez rare d'en voir si dans les
fronts martiniquais donc ça c'est des
signes de bonne santé de la mère ici
grâce à cette variété de poissons dont
nous ou la martinique serait une bonne
destination de chasse sous marine
c'est même une tradition de pêche ancré
dans notre culture des caractéristiques
nouvelles par rapport aux autres régions
de france
le but c'est de montrer à tous ceux qui
sont en métropole qui ont une idée des
antilles françaises parfois un peu
erronée de leur montrer ce que c'est en
réalité
donc effectivement il y aura des plans
sont par ailleurs des beaux poissons y
aura des beaufs ont dégradé belpech mais
est en même temps plein d'extérieur qui
montre ce qu'est la réalité de la
martinique ce côté végétation soleil
couleurs
la convivialité des gens qui habitent
ici donc voilà c'est un régal
son objectif donner plus de visibilité à
la martinique
l'histoire sera donc raconter à travers
les yeux de l'autochtone il connaît tout
du milieu aquatique de la météo et même
les coins secrets
aujourd'hui il sert de guide lui qui a
tout appris de son père j'espère qu'à
travers moi si certaines personnes
peuvent venir et qui t'a fait avant de
plus de poissons un marin pêcheur quitte
à faire un club de plongée mieux gagner
sa vie quitte à dire à leurs amis qu'ils
ont vu la martinique il faut vraiment y
aller
c'est ce qu'a économiquement pour mon
pays et autres c'est quand même quelque
chose
l'impression que ce 52 minutes
des interventions de scientifiques on
compte rendu sur l'état écologique de la
martinique et bien sûr quelques recettes
culinaires les fruits d'une pêche pour
les 600 mille abonnés de la chaîne
à découvrir en avril prochain